So, here's a common question.
Can you cry in space?
Do tears work?
Well, let's try it out.
I can't cry on command, but I'm gonna take some water, drinking water,...
...put it in my eye just as if I was crying.
Let's see what happens.
Get myself nice and stable for you here.
Here we go.
So, just as if I've started crying, my eye is full of tears.
But you can see, it just forms a ball on my eye.
In fact, I can put more water in.
And so if you keep crying, you'll just develop with a bigger and bigger ball of water in your eye,...
...until eventually, it crosses across your nose and gets into your other eye,...
...or evaporates or maybe spreads over your cheek or...
...you grab a towel and dry it up.
So yes, I've gotten things in my eye.
Your eyes will definitely cry in space.
But the big difference is, tears don't fall.
So grab a hanky.